[Guest] 未宣战的战争早已司空见惯。可悲的是，我们的政府发动先发制人的战争，也就是所谓的侵略，而美国民众对此却毫无怨言。
[Guest] 令人遗憾的是，我们已经习惯了政府以不正当方式使用武力。要建立一个真正自由的社会，就必须理解并拒绝主动使用武力这个问题。
[Guest] 如果有时候，爱你的国家就意味着你必须改革甚至废除政府呢？如果 Jefferson 是对的呢？如果最好的政府就是管得最少的政府呢？
[Guest] 如果当政府错了的时候，做对的事反而会有危险呢？如果为自由而战、哪怕牺牲，也比像奴隶一样活着更好呢？
[Guest] 如果自由最危险的时刻就是现在呢？
[Host] 大家好，我是 Andrew Napolitano 法官，这里是 Judging Freedom。今天是 2026 年 4 月 28 日，星期二。
[Host] John Mearsheimer 教授马上就到。Donald Trump 究竟是怎么输掉他主动选择发动的那场战争的？
[Host] 不过先看这个。
[Host] 当别人说“我早就告诉过你了”，你是不是也会尴尬得直起鸡皮疙瘩？ 抱歉，我早就说过，黄金和白银会因为过度印钞、通胀和全球不确定性而受益。
现在来了，已经发生了。 黄金和白银都创下了历史新高。
[Host] 你给 Lear Capital 打电话买一些了吗？ 现在还不算晚。 专家预测，接下来价格还会更高。 为什么？ 因为什么都没变。
地缘政治动荡、生活成本危机以及美元走弱，正推动各国央行增加黄金储备。
[Host] 预测显示，黄金可能涨到每盎司 6000 美元，白银可能涨到每盎司 200 美元。
就连 Morgan Stanley 都放弃了 60 比 40 的配置规则，改成了 60-20-20，把 20% 配到贵金属上。 他们已经开始补课了，你也该这样。
给业内最靠谱的人打电话。
[Host] 也就是我信任的那家公司，Lear Capital。 拿他们的报告，了解事实，买一些黄金和白银。
告诉他们是 the judge 介绍你来的，你最高可以拿到价值 2 万美元的额外黄金或白银。
拨打 800-511-4620，或者访问 leargjudgenap. com。
[Host] Mearsheimer 教授，欢迎您，我亲爱的朋友。和往常一样，感谢您配合这个时间安排。这件事有多重要？
[Host] 在您看来，伊朗外长 Arachi 此次访问莫斯科，而且是由 Putin 总统亲自、并且相当高调地出面迎接，这意味着什么？
[Guest] 我认为，这件事的影响不只是伊朗战争本身，它还关系到美俄关系，也关系到乌克兰局势的发展。我觉得，如果你仔细听听俄罗斯人最近在说什么，
[Guest] 尤其是 Lavrov 在 4 月 24 日发表的那场讲话，你就会发现，俄罗斯人基本上已经对美国人不抱希望了。他们明白，自己是在和整个西方交战。
[Guest] 尽管 President Trump 一再承诺要解决乌克兰战争、改善美国和俄罗斯的关系，但其实什么都没变。 这些根本没有发生。
我们依然把枪口对准俄罗斯人。
[Guest] 而这也让俄罗斯和伊朗越走越近。我觉得你看到 Arachi 去 St.
[Guest] Petersburg 和 Putin 会谈，而且两人进行了长时间讨论，这就说明双方已经形成了非常紧密的关系。
我还想特别指出，有各种证据表明俄罗斯人在帮助伊朗人。
[Guest] 在他们针对美国、以色列以及海湾国家部队使用无人机和弹道导弹这件事上，
[Guest] 很明显，俄罗斯在提供卫星数据，也在提供用于无人机和导弹的计算机芯片，这些武器会结合卫星数据使用，从而让伊朗的无人机和导弹具备致命的精准度。
所以我们面对的是一支非常难对付的。
[Guest] 海湾地区的双重作战力量，很大程度上就是因为俄罗斯在支持伊朗。而且再次强调，伊朗和俄罗斯已经被推到了一起，如今两者之间几乎没有任何距离。这些
[Host] 对。
[Guest] 天以来，我们针对的不只是俄罗斯，也包括伊朗，我们的政策就是如此。
[Host] 所以我们现在看到的这些照片，或者说我们在看的这些视频里，有……
[Host] 有外长 Rodger 和 Lavrov，还有公认的总统 Putin。Putin 本人亲自介入，这到底是在作秀，还是有实质意义？
[Guest] 我觉得这肯定是有实质意义的。我的意思是，这是高风险的外交博弈。这里面牵涉的，确实都是极其重要的问题。
[Guest] 除了实质内容之外，我觉得很有意思的一点是，俄罗斯人和伊朗人看起来是多么乐观、甚至有些轻松。
我觉得双方都明白，而且他们让美国人处在了被动防守的位置，
[Guest] 也就是我们在中东陷入了很大的麻烦，在乌克兰也陷入了很大的麻烦，而他们在很多方面都掌握着主动权。所以你看不出他们有任何深切担忧的迹象，
[Guest] 从你放的这段视频里，也看不出这两位领导人任何一方有悲观情绪。
[Host] 对，对。
[Guest] 伊朗人已经……
[Host] 显然，在最近一次沟通中——不管是直接沟通，还是通过巴基斯坦人传话，我不清楚——他们再次向美国人重申了自己坚定而一贯的立场：他们不会自愿放弃为民用目的进行铀浓缩的权利。
美国认真对待这一点吗？ 他们是否承认别的国家也有红线，有自己的想法，
[Host] 就像我们一样。
[Guest] 嗯，美国并不擅长接受别的国家也有红线这个观念。我们总觉得要么按我们的方式来，要么就别谈。
[Guest] 在核浓缩问题上尤其如此。 在 JCPOA 这件事上，我们当时被迫在这个问题上做出了一些妥协。
以色列人不喜欢那样，我认为他们也说服了 Trump，让他觉得 JCPOA 因此是个糟糕的协议。
[Guest] 而他当然也在 2018 年退出了这项协议。不过我觉得这里最有意思的是，美国人想做的是先从核问题谈起，也就是像你说的，先谈铀浓缩问题。
[Guest] 但随着伊朗最新提出的方案，他们已经把核浓缩这个议题挪到了必须处理的问题清单中的第三位。他们说，首先，我们必须实现有意义的和平。
[Guest] 我们必须结束这场冲突，而且还必须有某种保证，确保美国和以色列不会再次攻击伊朗。这是第一个要求。第二个要求是，之后他们才会谈 Hormuz 海峡。
[Guest] 当然，现在已经非常清楚，他们会在可预见的未来继续控制 Hormuz 海峡。所以在这一点上，他们不会对我们做出任何让步。然后第三，他们才会能够，
[Guest] 他们才会愿意谈核问题。换句话说，你基本上得先让冲突停下来，然后处理海峡问题，之后我们才能谈核问题。这不是美国人想要的。
[Guest] 美国人想把核问题放在最核心、最优先的位置。 但这一切都说明，随着时间推移，伊朗人对自己的处境越来越有信心。 这又回到我之前提到的 St.
Petersburg 里那些带着笑容的面孔。
[Host] 对。
[Guest] 而且我在这个节目里已经说过很多次了，时间站在伊朗这一边。在我看来，伊朗根本不着急达成协议。就让时间过去，让这场战争带来的经济后果慢慢显现出来。
[Guest] 那样会给美国人带来越来越大的压力。 美国人最后会妥协，而这会让伊朗人拥有更大的筹码。
所以你现在看到的是，借着这个新的三点方案，伊朗人其实是在更强硬地谈条件。
[Guest] 当然，Trump 总统对伊朗方面提出的这个新三点提案非常不满，因为正如我刚才说的，他想先把核问题解决掉。
[Host] 这是外交部长 Arachi 昨天感谢俄罗斯的讲话，来看第 12 段。
[Host] 正如你指出的，整个世界都已经看到，也向整个世界证明了，伊朗人民凭借他们的勇气，凭借他们在面对美国猛攻、面对美国侵略时的抵抗，将会……
[Host] 挺过这些考验，熬过这段时期。
[Host] 而且这也向所有人证明了，Tehran 是有朋友和盟友的，比如 Russia，在关键时刻会站在 Iran 身边。
我们感谢你们对伊朗伊斯兰共和国的支持。
[Guest] 嗯，这番表态还算得体，而且也是你会预料到他会在会谈接近尾声时公开说的话。
[Guest] 周日，Foreign Minister，不对，应该说 Secretary of State Rubio 发表了一些我认为不太理性的评论。
他谈起这个让我觉得很奇怪。
[Guest] 说什么和 Iran 的谈判完全不在考虑范围内。他根本就没去 Islamabad。
[Guest] 据我们所知，他并没有参与任何谈判；不像他之前的历任官员那样都会站在最前面，因为总统选择了他的两个盟友、他的女婿，还有他以前的生意伙伴。
[Guest] 不过你跟我说说你怎么看这个。关于 Hormuz Strait，Vice President Rubio 周日的那番话，来放第10段。
[Host] 周六，总统取消了在 Pakistan 的 Islamabad 举行的会谈，把特使 Kushner 和 Whitkoff 留在了美国国内。
他说，仅仅十分钟后，Iran 方面就提交了一份新的书面提议，而且条件更好了。
[Host] 如果他们所谓的开放海峡，意思是：没错，海峡是开放的，但前提是你得和 Iran 协调，得到我们的许可，不然我们就把你炸掉，而且你还得给我们交钱——那根本不叫开放海峡。
那是国际水道。
[Host] 他们不能把这种做法变成常态，我们也不能容忍他们试图把这样一种体系常态化——由伊朗来决定谁能使用国际水道，以及使用它要付他们多少钱。
[Host] 我刚才好像一不小心把他叫成了副总统 Rubio。其实他当然是国务卿。他是不是忘了，美国其实也在试图封锁 Hormuz 海峡？
[Guest] 当然。不过我只是想指出，他提到了这个所谓比之前方案更好的新提议。就像我几分钟前说的，这个新提议并没有更好。
[Guest] 这是个更差的提议。而且他不明白、总统也不明白的是，伊朗人不可能放弃对海峡的控制。他们要是放弃对海峡的控制，那才真是疯了。不只是眼下这场冲突期间，
[Guest] 而且在可预见的未来都不会。这就是他们筹码的来源。对海峡的控制，再加上他们手里的那些导弹——包括巡航导弹、弹道导弹，当然还有无人机。
[Guest] 他们不会放弃这些东西的。这就是他们的筹码。顺便说一句，关于国务卿 Rubio 没有参与谈判这件事。
[Guest] 你得明白，政府里有两个人极度想在 2028 年当上总统。 一个是 Marco Rubio，另一个是 J. D. Vance。
而且他们俩都明白，如果你卷入这些谈判，
[Guest] 到头来，你还是会不得不对伊朗人做出重大让步，因为现在掌握主动权的是伊朗人。这场战争我们基本上已经输了。
[Guest] 而如果你做出这些让步，如果你是那个负责拍板这些让步的人，你就会承受来自 Israel lobby 的巨大压力。
你会跟这个 lobby 闹僵，这也会让你更难当上总统。
[Guest] 所以你完全可以放心，J.D. Vance 对去 Islamabad、充当与伊朗人谈判的主谈人毫无兴趣。
[Host] 我不知道他还能不能把这件事洗干净，把手上的这个污点抹掉。我同意你的看法，但他可能已经留下无法磨灭的伤害了。
[Guest] 我觉得这很可能确实是这样。不过我还是想跟你说，
[Guest] Rubio 干得非常漂亮。
考虑到他既是 Secretary of State 又是 National Security Advisor，他一直设法不卷入这些谈判，因为我敢肯定他完全明白，自己就是不想牵扯进去，因为到最后我们会输，而 lobby 和 Israel 本身都会对任何妥协感到愤怒。
[Guest] 我们做出的任何妥协，真正去做这些妥协的人，都会付出相当大的政治代价。
[Host] 从伊朗人的角度看，他们肯定也知道，自己是在跟 Netanyahu 的傀儡谈判。
[Guest] 哦，当然。 他们已经把这点说得很清楚了。 所以他们才想让 Vance 来参加谈判。
他们知道 Kushner 基本上就是以色列的代理人，而且 Wittkopf 不光是个 Zionist，还已经相当明显地表现出——
[Guest] 不管是在跟伊朗人还是俄罗斯人谈判时，他都极其无能。所以他们不想跟那两个人打交道，他们想跟 Vance 谈。
[Guest] 而且他们确实在 4 月 11 日、12 日那个周末跟 Vance 接触过。结果并不怎么好。我的意思是，
[Guest] 现在必须发生的是，美国得感受到更多痛苦，世界也得感受到更多痛苦，并向美国施压，尽快结束这件事。否则，我们根本不会看到任何有意义的谈判。
[Host] Trump 是怎么输掉这场他自己选择发动的战争的？准备不足、没有明确可实现的军事目标、推进得太快、又被 Netanyahu 逼着出手。你怎么看？
[Guest] 他的策略从一开始就注定会失败。
[Guest] 我的意思是，以色列人说服了 Trump 总统，让他相信如果我们和他们一起对 Iran 发动一场“震慑打击”行动，而这场行动的核心是一套“斩首”战略，那么这就会导致该政权垮台。
[Guest] 然后扶植一个会听我们摆布的新政权。而且这会非常容易做到。我们会迅速而决定性地获胜。你要记住。
[Guest] 实际上，Trump 总统的几乎所有顾问都告诉他，这事很荒唐。唯一可能的例外是 Pete Hexeth。但正如我之前说过的，
[Guest] Pete Hexeth 不是个严肃的战略家。 我甚至不觉得连 Trump 自己都那么当回事。
但 General Kang、CIA 负责人 John Ratcliffe、Vance 本人，还有 Rubio，都说以色列人提出的那套战略
[Guest] 不太可能奏效。这是个很有意思的案例，因为所谓的深层政府，以及总统身边最主要的美国顾问，都警告他不要执行以色列人想出来的这套战略。
[Guest] 但 Trump 出于某种原因，还是决定跟着以色列人走，他们也执行了那套战略。我想在这里说清楚，那套战略注定会失败。
[Guest] 在有记录的历史上，我们找不出任何一个只靠空袭就推翻一个政权、而且还带来有利结果的案例。 这根本行不通。
你不可能只靠空中力量就在几天或者一周内实现政权更迭并打赢一场战争。
[Guest] 这种事就是不会发生。
我认为他的所有顾问都明白这一点，但总统还是让自己被 BB Netanyahu 以及 Mossad 负责人 David Barnea 给忽悠了，David Barnea 也是其中的关键人物，而且
[Guest] 我的意思是，
[Guest] 他正在为此付出代价——应该说，是我们在为此付出代价。
[Host] 对。
[Guest] 在这件事上。
[Host] 我们确实是这么看。你觉得他的顾问们，会不会因为他那种火山般的性格、对自己极其夸大的看法，
[Host] 思想上的空洞、拒绝阅读，把这些因素都加在一起，你觉得他的顾问们是不敢当面反驳他，还是不敢反驳 Netanyahu？
[Guest] 当然，这一点毫无疑问。 而且还是那句话，你得记住，我提到的那四个主要顾问里，有两个是 Marco Rubio 和 J. D.
Vance，他们俩都想当美国总统。 所以，
[Guest] 他们都想继续得到 Donald Trump 的欢心，也想继续得到 Israel 的欢心。 在很多方面，他们其实是被束缚住了。
他们能做的事情就是有限的。 而当 Trump 总统决定要做某件事时，
[Guest] 而且 Netanyahu 也支持同样的策略时，那像 Rubio 或 Vance 这样的人，想跟总统据理力争、告诉他这是个非常糟糕的主意，实际上能做的也非常有限。
顺便说一句，我觉得 General Kane，
[Guest] 很多人都在说他的坏话，但依我看，就公开记录所显示的情况而言，他在这件事上的表现是值得称赞的。Kane，他是 Trump 的
[Guest] 他亲自挑选的参谋长联席会议主席一路上多次告诉 Trump，我们并不具备实现他所追求目标的能力，这里的“他”指的是 Donald Trump。
而且，
[Guest] Cain 也告诉他们，如果我们和 Iran 开战，我们那些高端精确武器的库存会被消耗到非常危险的水平。 当然，这也正是我们现在的处境。
这也是最主要的原因之一。 是我们不想
[Guest] 重启这场战争。我们没有足够的武器装备来打这场仗。
[Host] Professor Mare Shimer，就目前来说，这个危险水平到底有多严重？我们知道吗？
[Guest] 不知道，我们不了解具体细节，但我们知道，已经用了大量大量的 Tomahawk 导弹，大量大量的 Patriot 导弹，THAAD 导弹也用了不少，
[Guest] 各种各样的智能炸弹都已经用了，这会对
[Guest] 遏制 China 以及 East Asia 的局势造成严重后果。
你之前也听我在节目里说过，我们本来应该把战略重心转向亚洲来遏制 China，但我们现在做的却是把重心从 China 身上移开。
我们正把各种军事力量从 East Asia 调往海湾地区，因为为了对付 Iran，我们需要尽可能多的武器。
而你面临的问题是，这些武器一旦消耗掉，你根本不可能在一个月内补回来。
[Guest] 别说一个月了，一年都不够。 要把我们已经消耗掉的这些武器重新生产出来，需要很多年。 我们不想让自己落到消耗更多武器的处境里。
但我想跟你强调的关于 General Kane 的一点是，
[Guest] 不出所料，他很早以前就意识到了这一点，也据此向总统提出了建议。 但 Trump 没听他的，因为 Trump 以为自己能迅速而决定性地取胜。
可一旦他没能迅速而决定性地取胜，
[Guest] 那他就陷入大麻烦了，而这正是我们今天的处境。 当然，这也是为什么军方现在在告诉 Trump：别打这场仗。
换句话说，别再重启这轮轰炸行动了，因为根本不会奏效。 当然，如果你不搞轰炸行动，又没有地面部队这个选项——而我们确实没有——那你就只能依赖海上封锁。
接下来问题就是，你觉得这种海上封锁能让伊朗人
[Guest] 屈服吗？ 我只能说，祝你好运吧。 这也不会发生。 你可以给伊朗人造成巨大的打击，但他们不会举手投降。
他们面对的是生存威胁，而当你面对生存威胁时，你会战斗到最后一个人。
[Host] 如果美国和伊朗达成某种长期和平协议，而且把 Israel 排除在外，会发生什么？
[Guest] 你知道，我想过这个问题。我觉得，让这个问题的这两个层面很难分开的关键连接点，是伊朗对 Hezbollah 和 Hamas 的支持。
[Guest] Israel 还会继续打击 Hezbollah，就拿这个例子来说，我们现在就看到了这种情况。 按说应该停火了，但事实上根本没有停火。
Hezbollah 和 Israel 还在继续互相开火，
[Guest] 而且在可预见的未来，这种情况都会持续下去。 但伊朗支持 Hezbollah，支持 Hamas，也支持 Houthis。
而且伊朗在任何情况下都不会放弃对这三个组织的支持。
[Guest] 这会让美国很难和伊朗达成一项有实质意义的和平协议，因为在这三个组织的问题上，Israel 和伊朗是不可分割、紧密相连的。
而美国当然又是和 Israel 绑定在一起的。
[Guest] 所以我觉得，这一切都说明，你不可能在这里达成什么有实质意义的和平协议。
[Guest] 你也许会得到某种很拼凑、很复杂的那种协议，暂时把火压一压，但根本看不到达成真正有意义的和平协议的希望。这在很大程度上是因为 Israel。
[Guest] 正如我长期以来一直在说的，实际上我和 Steve Walt 也这么论证过，你必须明白，Israel 对美国来说就是个沉重的大包袱。
我觉得越来越多美国人开始意识到这一点了。
[Guest] 但我们在中东陷入了很深的麻烦，而这一切都是因为 Israel，而且我们根本没有办法解决这个问题。
游说集团在美国影响政策制定者这件事上，力量实在太强了。
[Guest] 政策制定者这边也是一样，所以要想在解决这个问题上取得任何进展都非常困难。
顺便说一句，我们现在之所以没有朝着某种停火、甚至某种哪怕不太成熟的协议迈进，主要也是因为 Israel 和游说集团。
他们就是不肯让 Trump 和 Iranians 达成任何有实质意义的协议，他们希望战争继续打下去。
[Host] 那按你的看法，六个月或八个月之后，局面会是什么样？
[Guest] 嗯，我们也许会有某种很拼凑的协议，让商业运输能够通过这条海峡。可能不会有封锁。Iranians 会控制这条海峡。我很难相信我们会达成一项核协议。
[Guest] 核协议，我希望我是错的。但如果真有核协议，它看起来会有点像 JCPOA，也就是
[Host] 对。
[Guest] Iran 会坚持保有浓缩铀的权利和能力。而 Israel 永远不会接受这一点。那个游说集团也永远不会接受。
[Guest] 而且更广泛地说，这个国家里那些在政策圈影响力很大的新保守主义者，也永远不会接受。
[Guest] 所以，你知道，我们只会没完没了地就 Iran 的核能力跟他们争论，威胁他们，诸如此类。顺便说一句，如果你们在核问题上达不成一项有实质意义的协议，
[Guest] 那我们就会面临一种可能性：Israel 可能会动用核武器来对付 Iran，解决这个问题。所以这里的未来是——
[Guest] 很黯淡。顺便说一句，Europe 的未来也很黯淡。East Asia 的未来也一样黯淡。
[Guest] 我们把事情彻底搞砸了。
当然，这不只是 Trump 政府政策造成的结果，尽管这场 Iran 战争对此推波助澜很大，但 Ukraine 的整场灾难也一直没完没了地持续着。
[Guest] 而这将在可预见的未来带来极其严重的负面战略后果。正如我之前指出的那样，这些后果和 Gulf 正在发生的事情是密不可分地纠缠在一起的。
[Guest] 然后，这还先不谈整个东亚问题。东亚在很多方面其实是最危险的地区，因为美国在那里面对的是一个同级别的竞争对手。
[Guest] 一想到如果东亚爆发危机会怎么样，我就不寒而栗。我希望 Trump 能和 Xi Jinping 合作，确保那种情况不会发生。不过你得记住，
[Guest] 现在有两场重大战争正在进行，一场在海湾地区，另一场在欧洲，而东亚还没有战争。 但如果真有的话，我们可就真的陷入大麻烦了。
谢天谢地，我们现在还没有这个问题。 也希望，
[Guest] President Trump 能和 Xi 商量出个办法，避免那种情况发生。
[Host] President Trump 能和 President Putin 谈出什么结果？ 我的意思是，Putin 自己是不是也有他的难题？
你有没有感觉到，俄罗斯精英、Kremlin 官员以及普通俄罗斯人，对这场已经打了四年的战争都开始不耐烦了？
[Guest] 对，这一点毫无疑问。
[Guest] 我一直在想一种可能性，就是俄罗斯人自己某个时候可能会动用核武器。
很明显，欧洲人正在竭尽所能帮助乌克兰人，而乌克兰人现在也越来越擅长打击俄罗斯境内的目标。 最终的结果就是，俄罗斯的外交政策精英，甚至连……
[Guest] 甚至连普通民众，都开始急着想把这场战争了结掉。 他们正在给 President Putin 施加巨大压力，要他结束这场战争，但这并不容易。
我的意思是，即便俄罗斯人占领了越来越多的领土，
[Guest] 事实是，乌克兰人靠着这些无人机，以及他们从欧洲、甚至美国得到的各种援助，已经能够打击俄罗斯境内的目标了。问题在于，俄罗斯人会如何回应？
[Guest] 还有一位非常知名的战略家，我跟他其实还算熟，Sergei Karaganov，长期以来一直在主张，俄罗斯必须结束这种局面。
[Guest] 而唯一能做到这一点的办法，就是动用核武器，不是发动一场全面的热核战争，
[Guest] 而是以一种示范性的方式对西方使用核武器，向西方发出信号：够了。
如果他们继续支持乌克兰，并允许乌克兰摧毁俄罗斯的基础设施，那么俄罗斯接下来就会升级。
[Guest] 把核升级的阶梯往上推。Karaganov 认为，一旦对西方使用几枚核武器，他们就会清清楚楚地明白这个信号，也就会停止支持乌克兰。
[Guest] 但这里的关键点是，你不能把俄罗斯逼到绝境。
[Guest] 当然，欧洲现在恰恰就是在这么做。
就像我之前说的，Sergey Lavrov 在 4 月 24 日发表了一场非常重要、非常重要的讲话，我觉得大家很值得回头去看看那场讲话。
[Guest] 但 Lavrov 说得非常明确，他认为——当然，这反映的是俄罗斯的视角——西方已经对俄罗斯宣战了。他认为，俄罗斯正在与西方交战。
[Guest] 而且他认为，Russia 不只是在 Ukraine 境内和 Ukraine 作战。 Russia 其实也是在和 Europe 对抗。
他说得非常明确：他相信 Europeans 的目标，是要在战略上战胜 Russia。
[Guest] 而他这番话的基本意思是，Europeans——当然，这其实也指整个 West，他自己用的也是 the West 这个说法——是想把 Russians 从大国行列里打出去。
[Guest] 而当你在追求这样的目标，同时又对 Russian 的基础设施造成重大破坏时，你就是在给 Russians 很强的动机，逼他们采取强硬手段，甚至可能动用核武器。
[Guest] 我原本没想到局势会走到这一步。 说实话，我自己也很惊讶，我现在竟然会说出这样的话。
但我认为，绝不能低估 Ukraine 正在发生的事情，也不能低估那里的局势有多危险。 还有，
[Guest] 回到 Middle East 的话题，我刚才提到过 Israel 可能会使用核武器。
我并不是说这件事很可能发生，就像我也不是在说 Russians 很可能会使用核武器一样。
[Guest] 但你绝不能低估，一个国家在感到走投无路时会采取多么激进的行动。
你完全可以设想一些合理的情境：无论是 Israelis 还是 Russians，都可能陷入绝境，并开始考虑动用核武器。
[Guest] 顺便说一句，你要明白，如果 Israel 对 Iran 使用核武器，Iran 是没有能力进行报复的。
而如果 Russia 在 Ukraine 境内使用核武器，
[Guest] Ukrainians 也没有能力报复。 所以我们现在面对的是一个非常危险的局面。
再想想我们今天这期节目里的讨论，以及你这周在其他节目里和我们同事的讨论，
[Guest] 我觉得，大家对这些冲突接下来会走向哪里都非常悲观。 我们这些人里，说实话，没人能讲出一个圆满的结局，说明这些冲突会怎么收场。
而我认为，这应该让我们所有人都极其担忧。
[Host] 而我们也确实很担忧。 Mearsheimer 教授，非常感谢你。 感谢你就这两件事——Iran 和 Ukraine——所做的精彩分析。
亲爱的朋友，我们期待下周再见到你。
[Guest] 我也很期待，Judge。
[Host] 谢谢。今天晚些时候，关于这一切的更多内容，一点钟播出；两点钟是金童 Max Blumenthal。
[Host] Maco，美国军人会明知对方是无辜者还下手杀人吗？
还有，三点钟，Colonel Karen Kwiatkowski 在 Judge Knapp 上发表了一篇很精彩的文章。 我们是不是已经站在深渊边上了？
是不是已经站在疯狂的悬崖边了？ 我是 Judge Napolitano，这里是 Judging Freedom。